[Music]
hello everybody and thanks for joining
our session my name is Maria Garcia
puyol and I'm a software engineer on the
Android location and context team and
I'm also one of the cofounders of the
Android emergency location service which
helps find wireless emergency callers
faster now by a show of hands who in the
audience like me has ever dialed 911 see
number with their smart phone oh wow so
I can see a few let me share my story of
the one time i dialed 9-1-1 which is one
of the reasons why we started this
project in the first place in 2014
right after I had just joined Google I
bought my first car and this is me all
happy on that night about 10 minutes
after leaving the dealership I
encountered one of the scariest moments
of my life suddenly out of the blue out
of nowhere there was a woman standing in
the middle of the highway
I had to very quickly sort of to avoid
hitting her and luckily I didn't
immediately after I took my phone and
dialed 911 number in the United States
and after explaining what I had just
witnessed the first question they asked
me was where's your emergency and they
asked you this because to be able to
send you help right away they need to
know your precise location but today
over 80% of emergency calls are dialed
with smartphones in contrary to public
belief first responders may have a
really hard time locating you this is
because they rely on very inaccurate
location information as my colleague
Sunil will explain in a moment now back
to my story I was new to the area I had
just moved to the Bay Area to work at
Google and I didn't know where I was
everything that I was able to say was
I'm driving on some Highway in Mountain
View luckily for us other 9-1-1 callers
have reported the lady on the road and
they were able to dispatch help
but finding emergency colors may not be
as easy in many other situations we are
learning about this is that we rely on
very accurate location information for
pretty much everything in our lives
today you can get a pizza delivered to
your door from a nearby restaurant you
can upload a picture with the right
precise location on social media and you
can even get a date around you but
somehow that accurate location that you
see on Google Maps cannot be shared with
first responders so that they can find
you during an emergency so even though
you see the blue dot that you're so used
to and that you rely on for pretty much
everything nowadays a first responders
may not be able to say where you're
calling from in a big city I had just
joined the Android location team
so some colleagues and I sat down and
wondered if there was something we could
do to help fix this it boiled down to
one single question what if your mobile
phone could send its precise location to
first responders automatically by
precise location again I mean that
accurate blue dot that you see on Google
Maps we got very excited about this
possibility and a small team of us
started to work on this as a 20% project
so we spend 20% of our time roughly one
day a week at Google working on the
first prototype and we focused on three
basic founding principles the first of
them was that we wanted to make it
automatically available everywhere so we
decided to ship the Android emergency
location service as part of Google Play
services which is available on almost
every Android device out there and it's
updated regularly and that way users
don't need to download an emergency app
you just need to download the emergency
number
normally we wanted to protect the user's
privacy and so the location is computed
on the device on your mobile phone and
sent directly from your phone to first
responders
and only during emergencies and our main
goal was to improve the state of
emergency services around the world and
help save lives by providing more
accurate but also faster locations the
project became the Android emergency
location service or Els and I started to
get deployed in some countries in 2016
just two years later let me share with
you one of the most incredible examples
of how this technology is but is helping
save lives today it took place in
Austria last year
[Music]
a captain from our own heart
the Santa Clara appreciative season only
by three uncom there is too long our fan
cave is disabled
[Music]
just take it we tip the tonic
unfortunate Android the sanest can I'd
like to send it off in person didn't
feel too far off to feel
[Music]
and I'll help veining second metasoma
indefinitely because it's only become
[Music]
oh I'm gonna hand it over to my
colleague Sunil who's going to explain
what the state of emergency location was
when we started the project and why it
would have been very hard to find the
protagonist of our video thanks Maria
so I'm Sunil I'm the tech lead for ALS
it's great to be here with all you guys
today now we've all seen the Hollywood
movies or even TV shows where as soon as
there's a problem we can see a call
taker with a high-tech screen tracking
the callers location down to the exact
room they're in the reality not quite as
glamorous unfortunately so how is it
possible that Google Maps can know
exactly where you are but a 911 call may
not so we're gonna start with a quick
non comprehensive overview of how the
non-one system actually works in the
United States and what can go wrong
along the way so enon on one or enhanced
9-1-1 is a system in use in most of the
u.s. now enhanced 9-1-1 specifically
refers to the ability to get location
data alongside a call in the US 9-1-1
didn't exist until the late 60s and the
vast majority of what is now called the
e-911 system was developed in the 70s
when the only type of phone was a
landline email and one was of course a
huge advance in at the time before that
there was just a call there was no
location information whatsoever now some
quick pieces of trivia that red phone
you see up there is the actual phone
that the first not on one call was
placed on and below that a real picture
of one of the first call centers ever
built pretty high-tech for the time
right alright so this system was
designed in the 70s but it hasn't really
changed that much since then and even
today if you visit a 911 call center
much of the data even though it might be
presented on modern LCD screens is
likely delivered via serial cables let's
take a look at how this aging system
works behind the scenes in order to get
location the first thing that we want to
know about is called the alley or the
automatic location information database
the alley is essentially just a big
lookup table you get phone numbers in
one end street addresses out the other
this makes sense with landline phones
and landline phone is not going to be
changing street addresses very often but
as mobile phones came around the alley
had to be retrofitted support for a
latitude and longitude coordinates was
added carriers had to be able to push
cell or GPS location into this database
so we take a look at this real alley
record on the left there's a couple
things to notice first of all this is a
recent record this is from 2018 things
still work just like this today the
maximum record size here is 512 bytes
that's all the information we have to
work with here and in many call centers
those 512 bytes are delivered over a
1200 bps serial link now to do the math
quickly that means it takes 4.2 seconds
just to download this tiny amount of
information and get that in front of a
call taker now some other things to look
at first of all we have the address you
can see here this is a call 87
terrorists Street in Roxbury
Massachusetts we also have some latitude
and longitude information kind of also
bird in there is more accuracy and
confidence information that goes with
that now it was curious about this
address so I decided to take a look at
this on Google Street View here's what
we turn up this is a cell phone tower
the real call was pinging off this cell
phone tower but I bet that whoever was
calling was not located anywhere near
this address and not anywhere near these
latitude and longitude coordinates so
that's one problem with the e91 system
but there's another problem that better
location could help solve and that is
call routing now in the u.s. there are
6,000 call centers that handle emergency
calls alone and whenever you call 9-1-1
a decision has to be made which call
center is going to answer that call
usually this is done based on the cell
tower you're connected to it's pretty
straightforward usually works but there
can be problems
Sall towers will have often overlap
their range substantially the
jurisdictions that they serve can
overlap substantially all of this
complications mean that calls can easily
go to the wrong place and one that
happens the answering call center has to
manually transfer the call to the right
place and that incorrect routing eats
precious time out of every emergency
call to give you a quick example
it used to be the case that here in
California any emergency calls near
highways were routed to the California
Highway Patrol even if the call had
nothing to do with the highway and the
CHP call center was responsible for
triage in that call and then redirecting
it to local agencies as appropriate
now one study in Sacramento found that
this led to an average delay of almost
60 seconds just to transfer that call
from the CHP to the Sacramento Police
Department a 60 second delay on every
emergency call that really starts to add
up
so if Els is able to deliver highly
accurate location before the call starts
or even in the first couple seconds of
the call then we can route it to the
right place immediately instead of
routing it simply based on the cell
tower so at this point we've covered us
some background on Inanna one in the US
but we haven't really talked about the
rest of the world historically there
have only been four countries that
mandate GPS as part of their emergency
systems and that have enon on one system
similar to the US as you can see on the
map Canada the United States South Korea
and Japan for much of the rest of the
world emergency location is broken it
either doesn't exist or is only
supported by cell tower location
technology which is notoriously
inaccurate now this is the problem we
wanted to help fix and we designed the
Android emergency location system
provide accurate and quick fuse
locations to every country as we saw in
the video from Austria earlier so at
this point we've covered several of the
problems that we want to solve Els was
designed to bridge this gap providing
androids quick and accurate used
location directly to emergency services
as a supplement to existing enon on the
location and to be integrated with next
generation 9 1 systems so let's talk
about Els itself and let's start with a
high-level overview of how our service
works we can break this flow down into
four discrete steps first of course the
user has to call or text nine on one or
other emergency numbers such as 1 1 2
internationally and so forth as soon as
that call is made we start computing the
location on the device once we get the
location the next step is to send that
directly from the device to emergency
partners and it's direct and that it
does
travel through Google servers is then
the partners responsibility to send that
location on to the call center and to
make sure that it gets in front of the
call taker who can use that location on
their call so the left side of this is
broadly Google's responsibility and the
right side is broadly our partners
responsibility which brings us the next
point what exactly is a partner so
generally we work with three types of
partners there are government agencies
there are carriers and operators and
third party emergency services companies
so with over six thousand call centers
in the US alone we rely on our partners
and their public safety expertise to get
this location delivered exactly where it
needs to go so there's the overall flow
how do we configure and control this
well google administers this on behalf
of our partners and we have an
incredibly flexible configuration system
that supports all kinds of things I'll
touch on just a couple we support
arbitrary Geographic polygons this lets
us control our activations at a county
level or a state level rather than just
at the country level
it lets us touch on you know all sorts
of different jurisdictions we can use
the country code and network code from
cell towers to help base our logic based
on the country and carrier that this
call is coming from and of course we
support location updates for the entire
duration of the emergency call instead
of just a single update so somebody made
in nine one call or get the location now
we need to send it how do we do that at
the moment we use two methods either an
HTTP message or SMS message we're gonna
examine both well let's start by
examining the SMS message in a little
more detail now when we first started
thinking about Els it happened that
British Telecom in the UK had proposed a
new standard for location over SMS
messages this was called the advanced
mobile location format or AML we adopted
AML and it's now common everywhere in
Europe there was one other thing we had
to think of we originally started
experimenting using normal text messages
the kind you might send to your friend
every day but there's one problem
there's no way to keep this from being
exposed in the users outbox and this
presents a privacy concern
now if you've ever called 9-1-1 from
your android device and it sounds like a
lot of you had to you may have noticed
that that number one call does not show
up in your call log there's a good
reason for this in a lot of cases such
as domestic violence situations it's
actually very important that there is no
evidence on the phone that somebody has
had to contact emergency services that
the users privacy is preserved so
instead we switch to data SMS this is
simply a subset of the normal SMS
standard that allows for binary payloads
but more importantly does not show up in
the user's outbox and helps us preserve
the users privacy a couple other things
I want to mention as the message
generally functions better in lower
signal coverage it doesn't require a
data connection of course this makes it
very useful to us in emerging markets it
may require some coordination with
carriers of course
so let's contrast SMS with HTTPS now the
first and most important difference for
us is just HTTP can handle much more
information it's not size limited like
an sm SMS is it's very flexible and more
importantly extensible so you can add
new information add new key value pairs
to help give our partners more
information and you know help save lives
that way now we found that when a
high-quality data connection is present
HTTPS actually turns out to be more
reliable than SMS generally of course
this depends on your cell environment
your signal environment the the country
you're in a whole bunch of things but
overall we see HTTPS is the way forward
but we're unwilling to live out leave
out incumbent markets so we encourage
our partners to use both options
whenever possible so now that we have a
high-level understanding of how we
transmit location the next piece of the
puzzle is how we actually figure out
where the phone is in the first place so
to tell you a little bit about the
Android fused location provider here's
Steve great thanks to Neil hello
everyone my name's Steve malkos and I
also helped co-found Els I'm super
excited to be here with you all today
now let's talk about how location is
computed because getting an accurate
location is the key to all of this the
faster and more accurate location we
could deliver the
or people we can help accuracy and speed
of location will reduce the emergency
response times here's a great quote from
the US government
the FCC estimates that 10,000 lives
could be saved every year for one minute
sooner if the user was calling the
emergency dispatching Center that's a
very powerful statement one minute
sooner having the potential to save
10,000 additional lives every year it's
quite powerful okay so what you saw
earlier from Sunil was that the existing
emergency system today either used a
cell based position or GPS based
position let's first focus on cell cell
tower positions to emergency responders
are not considered a location that they
could dispatch help to that's because
the emergency operator is seeing the
Civic address to the nearest cell tower
and that's nowhere near where the actual
emergencies being is taking place and
cell tower position ranges in the
thousands of feet or hundreds of meters
like in this example where we see the
cell tower position at our office is
over 2,000 feet or 600 meters GPS
everyone in this room is pretty much
aware that GPS works great when we're
outdoors in the open sky environment
like in this example where we see GPS
position fix of about 25 meters or 85
feet
this was taken indoors and it's not that
good of a position GPS doesn't work that
well indoors this is the true location
where we were when we did this example
but when you're outside in a pure open
sky environment GPS is typically around
five to six meters or nine to ten feet
there are many issues with getting GPS
into the legacy emergency dispatching
system I'm going to highlight two of
those today the first issue is that when
the GPS position is computed it's
actually computed on the carrier's
network it's not the location that's
available on your mobile device which is
much more accurate the second issue is
that the carrier is only
shooting a single GPS position fix where
as Els can compute multiple fixes
throughout the entire duration of that
call so more or less GPS has you covered
for the most part when you're outdoors
in an open sky environment but what
about a downtown dense deep urban area
or when you're indoors or deep indoors
that's where we can help with our
comprehensive positioning solution which
includes indoor and outdoor locations we
call it the fused location provider or
FLP the fused location provider is
comprised of Wi-Fi GPS and sensors to do
sensor fusion that gets us this very
accurate location and the fused location
provider is available on almost every
Android handset in the market today
in this example the FOP is able to
compute a very accurate position indoors
right here we produce the position at
about 29 feet or nine meters earlier
today there was a talk on at Google i/o
called seamless and smooth location
everywhere with the new fused location
provider if you didn't get a chance to
see it live watch it on YouTube ok so
this is the flow from the lower hardware
to the fused location provider it looks
something like this there's many
different location providers in Android
let's say as an app developer which most
of you are in this room wanted to create
an app that only acts as GPS only
locations you could do that by calling
the location manager API is in Android
or let's say you wanted to build an app
that only access to Wi-Fi locations or
cell-based locations then you could call
the NLP or the network location provider
but if you simply wanted to get the best
of what Google offers which uses all the
different location providers along with
the sensors doing sensor fusion our
recommendation is to access the FOP
directly the fused location provider
fuses all these technologies together in
order to derive the best possible
location and that's what we supplied to
the emergency respond
others so the FOP is ubiquitous it works
globally by providing 3d locations in
all different types of environments
we're especially proud of launching
altitude or 3d location for indoors so
now we provide 3d XYZ locations not only
for outdoor environments but also
indoors the FOP is fast gps can
sometimes take a very long time to get a
position fix the Apple P is almost
instant on and gives you very quick
location updates as you move around this
is important as we noted earlier because
the Sooner help is sent the better and
the FLP is accurate according to the EPA
the Environmental Protection Agency the
average American spends 87% of their
time indoors this is including while
they sleep as well so the FOP needs to
work and it needs to work accurately
especially when we meet need at most
wall indoors ok demo time as we were
planning this demo for Google i/o we
said we wanted to do a demo that people
could relate to so we went to one of the
most recognizable places that we could
think of
I could hear Sean Connery's voice right
now from the movie The Rock okay let me
try this on you welcome to the rock or
otherwise known as Alcatraz Island thank
you but Alcatraz has its own set of
challenges it has lots of metal super
thick concrete walls and tiny tiny
windows this is not conducive for good
GPS or Wi-Fi signaling conditions when
computing our fused location provider
positions but we said we like challenges
let's see how well we'll do so we worked
with the San Francisco emergency
dispatching Center who allowed us to
place real calls into their center what
this demo will show us is the boys from
the call taker will be receiving
locations nowhere near the actual
emergency where that's taking place but
I'd like you to pay 10
- how quickly the look the location
shows up on the phone and how quickly
the location shows up on the laptop with
the red blinking dite dot that's very
accurate update from Els even before the
call is connected let's play the clip
I have one of our people reporting hi
this is a test call from Google I was
reaching out to see if I can get the
address on your screen
hold up 6-0 hold 8 can you repeat that
one more time
6 1 0 hold a perfect can I also get the
latitude and longitude latitude three
seven point eight zero four three one
four zero zero longitude a negative one
to two point four five one three to
eight perfect thank you very much okay
do up
what we saw from the legacy emergency
system is unfortunately very common the
dispatch operator noted a latitude and
longitude which mapped to the nearest
cell-tower address both these locations
were to over two point five miles away
from the actual emergency but what we
saw with Els is the location shown here
in red was right on top of the true
location and it and it could have also
been available to the emergency
responder even before that call was
answered we're really excited about this
service and its potential to help more
and more people globally next up you'll
hear from Fiona who will talk to us
about some of the challenges around
launching Els globally thanks Steve
so Sanel Steve and Maria have described
how we engineered Els and I think we've
shown you that Els provides more
accurate location faster than legacy
e-911 location solutions but just
because you build a better technology
does not mean that people are actually
going to use it so I'm going to talk to
you about how we launched Els around the
world and I'm gonna focus on the
non-technical factors that played a key
role in our ability to successfully
deploy Els on a global scale now don't
get me wrong we didn't have all the
answers on day one but we listened to
our users we learned and we iterated
over time so the first factor to keep in
mind is the ecosystem what are the
characteristics of the community of
people who will use your product or
service what's the environment in which
they operate what products do they
currently use today with Els we focus on
two sets of target users the public
safety professional and the end-user who
will just dial or text an emergency
number and expect it to work so when we
looked at the public safety ecosystem
the first thing that jumped out at us is
that it is disparate and fragmented so
you have some countries with just a
handful of emergency communication
centers and then you have the US with
over 6500 that's more than all the
emergency communication centers in
Europe there are some emergencies
that are only staffed by two people and
then there are some that have hundreds
of thousands of people taking emergency
calls they all use different IT systems
in the u.s. we have one emergency number
911 is 50 so what that told us was that
we have to build Els to be very flexible
and to offer options and so they will
walk you through all the different
configuration options that we provide
second thing about public safety is that
it is rife with legacy infrastructure
this tends to be expensive proprietary
have high upgrade costs and high
switching costs so what we did was
rebuilt Els so it's standards-based
right so data SMS adheres to the
advanced mobile location specification
and HTTP as is HTTP the benefit of
adhering to standards is that it makes
it very easy for your partners to deploy
there's a uniform process to deploy we
also design each Els to be fast and easy
so we can turn on a new configuration we
can change configurations and we can
roll that all out in under 24 hours
finally we design yell us to be safe
when we decide on a production rollout
we work with our partners to role yell
us out in phases we usually start at 1%
we let that soak for a few days then we
increase to 5% soak some more and we
increase in increments and at any point
in time it is really easy to roll back
the second factor to the third factor to
keep in mind is Public Safety is risk
averse right so lives on the line the
cost of making a mistake are very very
high so we built LS as I said to be safe
and to roll out in phases
the second factor to keep in mind is
your distribution or business model how
do you plan on getting your product into
the hands of users as developers it's
really important for you to find a
distribution model that can scale
rapidly for us we made LS free free to
partners free to public safety mostly
because it is the right thing to do when
we want to keep Android users safe but
free is good free promotes adoption and
Public Safety likes free because they
tend to be budget constrained
second key decision we made was to
distribute Els via Google Play services
this gave us a scalable distribution
mechanism and it allowed us to be
ubiquitously available because Google
Play services ships with just about
every approved Android phone the other
nice thing about going out with Google
Play services is that Google Play
services updates over weeks that meant
we could roll out Els updates quickly
and not be tied to an annual OS release
cycle and then finally we built Els to
be user first for the user who cares
about privacy we offer an opt-out
feature and as my colleagues have said
we calculate location on the device and
we only activate Els when an emergency
call is made now there were trade-offs
in this right because you can offer much
more functionality when you do service
site processing but we made a decision
not to do that the other thing about LS
is the user doesn't have to take any
action no special hardware required on
the phone no need to download an app if
LS is deployed in your region you just
dial and text the emergency number and
it will work for the public safety
professional we design Els so that els
can be easily integrated into one of
their existing systems so I don't know
if you've ever seen an emergency call
taker but they are juggling about five
different screens on their desk and the
last thing we want to do is force them
to have a six screen in order to get LS
location data so one of our best
practice recommendations to partners is
integrate Els location data into one of
the existing systems currently used at
the emergency communication center
usually the mapping system of the
computer aided dispatch system finally
Els is future friendly we have built it
so that it will be easily integrated
into next generation public safety
systems that are being designed all over
the world this third factor is my
personal favorite regulation what are
the laws pertaining to your product and
service who makes those laws and how
explicit is the language so as you might
expect there is a lot of regulation
surrounding public safety it's a
mission-critical service and
government's want to keep people safe
and for Els as an additional implication
for us because we
transfer because we transmit location
during an emergency called our privacy
implications as well so when we look at
regulation the first thing we notice is
that laws are lagging regulators simply
cannot keep pace with technology so we
position Els as a supplemental service
it's not meant to replace existing
emergency location solutions it's meant
to augment it and provide the 911 sea
call taker with another tool in their
toolkit
second thing about laws is believe it or
not they can be ambiguous especially
laws that pertain to privacy with
respect to emerging new technologies so
when we looked at some countries we
found that you know there were no
explicitly explicit laws saying that you
cannot transmit location during an
emergency but there were no laws that
explicitly said you can as well so this
is gray area and we chose to exercise
due diligence and caution and we decided
to calculate location on the device so
they and then transmitted it directly to
our partners so that no personally
identifiable information is stored on
Google servers finally laws are complex
there are different regulatory
frameworks and privacy laws in each
country
these laws believe it or not can be
sometimes contradictory often
overlapping and in the case of Els
generally multi-jurisdictional
because you make an emergency call over
the telecommunications network or you
send an emergency text over the
telecommunications network we had to
deal with the ministry of
telecommunications we also had to deal
with the Ministry of Interior which is
generally responsible for Public Safety
sometimes the Ministry of Defense and
the Ministry of Health and then there
were also data protection agencies that
we had to keep in mind last but not
least is partnerships so good partners
are bridges we view our partners as a
scaling force multiplier and this is
particularly true in public safety
because Public Safety tends not to be an
early adopter of technology so we rely
on our partners to educate and train
Public Safety and also to work with them
to operationalize Els location data so
it can be useful in the emergency
communications center so what we do is
we look for partners that have really
high standards in
Quality Assurance insecurity in
monitoring in reporting and in
operational support this ensures that we
have a high quality end-to-end
deployment of Els so how are we doing
today today Els is live in eighteen
countries serving a population of six
hundred plus million users and we send
location for over one and a half million
emergency calls per day one of the nice
things about being on the Els team is
learning about how Ellis has made a
difference in emergencies around the
world so I'd like to share a couple of
stories with you the first one has to do
with a medical emergency in Lithuania
eight-year-old boy calls emergency
services he's found his father
unconscious maybe dead he doesn't know
his home address he doesn't know the
phone number of any of his family
members
now remember Lithuania Public Safety
does not get location by a GPS only cell
so the call taker is seeing a cell tower
location of a whopping 14 kilometers
almost nine miles in a densely populated
neighborhood that's hundreds if not
thousands of houses that you have to
search but thanks to Els which
pinpointed the exact house where the boy
made the call
accuracy radius of six meters the first
responders could be dispatched to render
medical help really quickly and as it
turns out the man was suffering from an
epileptic seizure second instance is a
serious mountain biking accident in
Austria mountain biker was alone had a
bad accident in a deeply forested area
no landmarks no addresses cell tower
location was 900 plus meters but thanks
to Els which gave a 12 meter accuracy
radius they could send medical help to
the injured biker to take him to the
hospital because they could locate him
quickly so I'd like to hand the
microphone back to Maria to wrap up
thanks for you enough so now that you've
learned more about how the Android
emergency location service works I'd
like to close the session with some
final thoughts
Thanks - LS your Android phone is able
to send accurate location in 18
countries during emergencies - first
responders
but for us this is just the beginning
we're working on deploying the Android
emergency location service in more
countries because we'd like to help as
many people as possible also even though
our location accuracy is much better
than the existing legacy location
systems in emergency services we're
always working on improving location
both indoors and outdoors in one of our
very next challenging goals and we like
challenges is to provide dispatchable
addresses and also floor numbers to
first responders so that they can find
you when you dial an emergency number
even faster I for one am very proud of
the impact Els has had on people's lives
and I'm very happy to know that if I
were to dial 911 today because I found a
person standing in the middle of the
highway first responders would be able
to locate me right away here in Mountain
View this product of course wouldn't
have impossible with the help of our
many partners and collaborators around
the world so we want to give them a
special thanks and also thank you all
very much for coming to Google i/o and
for coming to a session please reach out
if you have any questions or wanna know
more that's all from us thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
you